ein bericht sorgt aktuell für aufregung
nämlich aus dem us-kongress der ganz
offiziell sagt er es ist davon
auszugehen dass das virus hier sehen wir
das deckblatt dieses berichts des us
kongresses tatsächlich aus einem labor
in hahn stammt
wie stehen sie dazu folgen sie dieser
theorie und vor allen dingen was
bedeutet das jetzt für sie für die
deutsche politik wenn nach und nach das
eben nicht mehr in den bereich der
gerüchte der
verschwörungstheorie lebt legt sondern
wenn der us-kongress tatsächlich ein
stempel drauf macht und sagt ja davon
gehen wir aus stammt aus dem
chinesischen labor aus wo hahn
soweit ich weiß ist dass jetzt noch ein
bericht der von einer der parteien
angefordert wurde und dann abgegeben
würde das ist jetzt ganz entscheidend
sie haben völlig recht diese billig wird
dort diskutiert dann muss natürlich auch
mal die us regierung als ganzes dazu ein
statement abgeben es würde dann sehr
interessieren und auch deutschland muss
diese nicht genau studieren und dann
seine analysen daraus ziehen und möglich
über mögliche konsequenzen diskutieren
ich würde mich da jetzt noch
zurückhalten wenn das so wäre wäre das
schon eine sehr spannende und
herausfordernde situation insbesondere
deswegen weil es dazu keine äußerungen
gegeben hat bislang aber das muss jetzt
mal abschließend geklärt werden auf
jeden fall wird diese bericht für
erhebliche diskussionen sorgen für
diskussionen und vor allen dingen für
schadenersatzforderungen also das liegt
er jetzt auf der hand wenn sich eben es
wurde ganz lange als
verschwörungstheorie abgetan von
deutscher politik von deutschen
wissenschaftler auch von herrn drosten
unter anderem und jetzt rückt das aber
immer mehr in den in den bereich ja
stempel drauf alle hinweise deuten
darauf hin dass heißt das verändert ja
völlig die politische debatte um
schadenersatzforderungen
ich würde mal sagen wir sehen diesen
bericht den ich selber ja nicht gelesen
habe bislang ich habe über die
berichterstattung jetzt darüber fahren
und deswegen wird es natürlich sehr
akribisch genau analysiert werden sowohl
noch einmal der us-regierung ist schon
wichtig aber dass der präsident der
vereinigten staaten und seine regierung
dazu sagt ist es die dem offizielle
meinung der usa dann muss das über die
whu auch diskutiert werden auch der an
stellungnahme ist wichtig der
bundesregierung und dann wenn diese
ergebnisse gesichert wären dann hat es
sicherlich eine weitere diskussion zu
folgt also
ich weiß dass man da aus dem ersten
impuls heraus gerne mehr fordern möchte
aber erstmal eins nach dem anderen
diskutieren stimmt es wirklich in
welcher form in welchem umfang und und
dann sehen wir weiter aber wenn diese
frage noch mal abschließen solange im
bereich der verschwörungstheorie war
dann haben wir uns doch offenbar bisher
nicht abschließend damit oder nicht
ausreichend damit beschäftigt wir hatten
ja auch selber seitens der
bundesregierung mehr so ein bericht
anfertigen können oder im parlament
ja guter zugang erfolgt über andere
möglichkeiten also da würde sie einfach
sehr spannend sein wie dieser bericht
bewertet wird ob man den selbst als
glaubwürdig eingestuft wird das
überhaupt keine zweifel daran schön im
gegenteil aber das muss jetzt alles mal
eingestufte ich würde es einfach mal
vorschlagen das ist etwas für die für
für dieses gespräch in zwei oder drei
wochen ok trotzdem wollten sie diese
frage überhaupt geklärt haben bisher
wollte die deutsche politik diese frage
geklärt haben war sie daran interessiert
oder sicher ist ja ganz entscheidend ist
ja ganz entscheiden woher kommt corona
woher grund corona und durch was ist es
verursacht worden ist ja ganz
entscheidend